well good morning
to the graduates of 2014
congratulations i know that i'm the last
thing standing between you and your
diplomas
so i feel a tremendous responsibility
to be brief to to everyone
who is here this morning to celebrate
the graduates
welcome to mit and to the parents
and families of today's graduates
congratulations to you
as well for you this day
is the joyful result of years of
serious effort loving support
and sacrifice and please accept our
deepest gratitude
and admiration it is great to have you
all here on killian court on this
wonderful day for this tremendously
important
occasion but before we let you graduate
i'm expected to give our graduating
class
a charge that's
a fancy way of saying that i'm supposed
to give you
some advice since you've gotten
yourself this far without my advice it
isn't clear
that you need any from me now except
perhaps watch your step going down that
ramp quite frankly
coming up with advice that would be
useful for people
as talented as you are is a big
challenge
so i'm going to distract you for a
minute with some advice that was given
to me
by some of your fellow mit students
when i took on the job of president two
years ago
a group of students volunteered to
advise me
they call themselves the presidential
transition advisory cabinet
at the end of the first year they
decided they were
so good at giving me advice they would
just keep
doing it one of our meetings was last
september
it was a great conversation and i did
not want to leave it
but i told them that i had to end the
meeting
they were surprised and they teased me
about it
why do you have to go they ask what
could you
possibly have to do that is more
important
than talking to us i explained
that i had to see some alumni who were
members of the william
barton rogers society i
said these are graduates whose
generosity
make it possible for you to be at mit
that impressed them so i asked the
students
is there anything you wish me to tell
this important alumni after a moment
one of them replied please tell them
that mit
is a gift to the world
mit is a gift to the world
i actually believe that's true and i
believe it more than ever
being here today with all of you
because i know that you
you are graduates are a gift
to the world now
i would also like to feel certain that
the world is ready for you
so since i believe i know you pretty
well
i think i should give the world some
instructions
for your care and feeding
so i could write a letter it might go
something like this congratulations on
your recent decision to hire
invest in launch a startup with enroll
marry date or befriend your new mit
graduate
mit graduates are fairly exotic
only around 130 000 of them
exist in the wild
they vary widely in appearance
although over time they do tend to
acquire bright red jackets
but they all share certain powerful
instincts here are some answers
to frequently asked questions about
handling your new
mit graduate to achieve the best
results question
this is addressed to you ms corbin too
question my company has a very
competitive culture
but my new mit graduate insists on
building collaborative teams
what am i doing wrong
answer there is no way to stop this
team-building behavior
and be careful it spreads
monitor your entire company for symptoms
of increased
creativity and profits
question is there any way to discourage
my new mit graduate from working
all night
answer mit graduates are naturally
nocturnal especially
when they are chasing a fresh idea
you can try locking your new mit
graduate inside a frustrating
bureaucracy
for a short time this will stun them
but they will quickly escape and return
to quantum
leaping
question i have a group of new mit
graduates
i recently fed them a huge quantity of
raw data
and unleash them on an extremely hard
problem
now how do i make them stop
pouring
answer warning do not tell them the
problem is
impossible or critically important to
the future of humankind
that will only make the purine worse
if you cannot stand their appetite for
tough
meaningful challenges consider trading
them for new graduates from
some other institution
question i want my new mit graduates to
perform
at the peak of their abilities what can
i use to motivate them
well you can try bunny
that works up to a point
but if you really want to see how high
your new mit graduates can jump
give them an opportunity to change the
world
so that is my advice to help the world
understand you
let me complete my assignment and give
you
some advice
as you start out in life it can seem
that society
runs itself you may feel that
for the most part it proceeds according
to forces
outside the control of any individual
sort of like a driverless car
but at least for now we as a society
still need our most thoughtful
inventive compassionate people in
the driver's seat we need
your vision to steer around
obstacles your passion to accelerate our
progress
towards important goals and your wisdom
to put the brakes on humanity's most
destructive forces
and more often than you might think
we need you to get out of the car open
the hood
reach for your tools and rebuild the
engine
of society until it delivers
the kind of performance we expect from
ourselves
at mit whatever road
you choose to travel i want you to
reject the idea
that what you see in front of you is the
best
that we human beings can do
i want you to see the status quo as
nothing more than
the beta release a place to start
because you know we can do better
in short and i think some of you may
know what's coming
i want you to hack the world until you
make the world
a little more like mit more daring
and more passionate more rigorous
playful and ambitious
more humble more respectful more
generous
and more kind it is a big assignment
but i know you're ready because you came
to mit with exceptional qualities
of your own and you leave us now
equipped with a rare set of skills
and steeped in this community's deepest
values a commitment to excellence
integrity meritocracy
boldness humility an
open spirit of collaboration a strong
desire to
make a positive impact and a sense of
responsibility
to make the world a better place
on this wonderful day i'm proud of
all of you so now
go out there join the world find your
calling
solve the unsolvable shape the future
drive society onto the high road
and you will continue to make your
family including your mit family
proud to every one
of the members of the graduating class
of 2014
please accept my best wishes for a happy
and successful life and career and
congratulations